mais quand même la preuve premier
obstacle en dehors des petits pas de
côté sur le tapis rouge
qu'a fait françois hollande est
rectifiée par la chancelière
quand il a fallu justement honoré
l'armée sur place
il ya quand même l'idée que macro mise
sur l'europe et que la rendent compte de
minceur avec la chancelière est décisive
c'est une réponse décisive oui bien voir
à l'image emmanuel macron qui quitte
donc ce parc de l'elysée où la pluie a
fait son apparition à elsa puis c'est le
retour de la pluie alors qu'il faisait
beau il est encore quelques minutes
lorsqu'il a passé les troupes en revue
emmanuel macron qui va donc se diriger
vers la grille du coq où il quittera
l'elysée un emmanuel macron qui a l'air
de prendre ce mauvais temps avec humour
puisque il sourit en soulignant la pluie
françois hollande dit gouverner c'est
pleuvoir
il faut mais il faudra voir l'attitude
des malins vaincrons s'il peut
effectivement pendant qu'ils remontent
les champs-elysées en voiture alors
françois hollande avait bien détrempé
sous des trombes d'eau il est
vraisemblable alors que si la pluie
continue et qu'elle tombe relativement
fort emmanuel macron peut-être restera à
l'intérieur la voiture et saluera
peut-être seulement les les français de
la main pour éviter cette cette image
qui ensuite a poursuivi françois
hollande tout au long du quinquennat
exactement c'est pour ça que la météo ça
peut paraître anecdotique mais ce sont
des images qui restent dans l'histoire
et qui du coup bien sûr ça change s'il
fait un grand soleil plutôt que si là il
pleut énormément on voit emmanuel macron
qui est en train de rejoindre à pied on
imagine ce qui va être sa voiture
parlons un palan faune et le routard et
de l'explication c'est le le tempo
mitterrandien qu'il est en train
d'installer délicatement et son d'oise
mans peut-être qu'ils m'aiment on voit
on marque un petit temps d'arrêt dans le
parc de l'elysée
visiblement en discussion emmanuel
macron on a l'air de s'interroger pour
l'instant surtout pas venir la voiture
voilà malheureusement la pluie ne va
peut-être pas s'arrêter tout de suite
donc il faudra faire avec pour le tout
nouveau président de la république on
vous